Hùng hàng không Việt Nam vừa có văn bản vui các tổng công ty, hàng không Việt Nam,
càng hàng không Việt Nam, các công ty của phần.
Với chết, chế Việt, bà C. FIC L. L.
L. Hùng Việt Nam về việc giả sóa, cấp nhật thông tin liên quan đến địa giới hàng chính mới.
Theo nghĩ quý số 2.5 2.5 mc, mở làm và các nghĩ quý linh quan,
tế từ ngày 1 mồ tháng 7.5 mc.
Bíng sắp sẽ đưa chính địa giới hàng chính và áp dụng mô hình chính quyền địa phương
hai cấp đã chính pức được chính khai trên bản quốc.
Một số địa giành hàng chính gản với các càng hàng không cũng có sự thay đổi từng ứng.
Để bảo đam tính chính xác, minh bà thận tiện cho hành khách trong quá trình mô vẽ,
tiếp cận thông tin quảng 3 xần phần.
Cục hàng không Việt Nam yêu cầu các hàng hàng không phần chương giả sóa thật và cập nhật các thông tin hiển thị trình vẽ.
Với xài bản vẽ, các càng phần phối cũng như ấn phần quảng 3 xần phần.
Dưới thiệu điểm đến cho phù hợp với địa giới hàng chính mới.
Các hàng hàng không cũng được địa nghĩ phối hợp chật chế với các càng hàng không trong việc cập nhật thông tin về dịch vụ.
Bảo đam tính đồng bộ và chính xác của giữa liệu liên quan đến địa dành hành chính.